au cas où vous l'auriez déjà oublié 2004
et est aussi l'année de la culture à
lille ne trois mois après le lancement
de l'événement l'office du tourisme
avait du mal à cacher sa joie notamment
considéré qu' à une augmentation notoire
en janvier puisque l'année dernière on a
reçu à l'office de tourisme 12 mille
personnes et cette année trente mille
personnes ont franchi des pas ici du
palais rihour
et pourtant ce n'était qu'un début les
deux mille manifestations de l'année
ombre et nice 7 million et demi de
personnes ont tout sans vous gaver deux
chiffres en vrac 60000 visiteurs ont
traversé le tri postal 48 ils ont
apprécié les mondes parallèles oui mais
l'artiste se sont produits avec quelques
temps forts rubens au palais des
beaux-arts picasso à la piscine de
roubaix ou encore l'expo mexique europe
record absolu en termes d'entrées le
nombre d'entrées de l'office de tourisme
par rapport à une année normale à
doubler pratiquement nous avons donc
enregistré 800 milles entre r on
s'attendait en effet par rapport déjà à
ce qu'on nous avait dit par rapport à
d'autres capitales européennes à 30
voire 40 % d'augmentation
mais dans de telles proportions avec un
tel engouement et surtout un tel
enthousiasme et puisque je crois
vraiment le public était tout à fait
satisfaits de leur visite à lille et
sans aucun doute je crois qu'on a permis
en effet de conforter la ville comme une
grande destination touristique
+ 33 % du nombre de nuitées aussi pour
les hôteliers du coin britanniques
belges allemands italiens américains
chinois
ils sont venus en cars et en masse ça
donc c'est vrai qu'on a envie de venir
de connaître le nord moi je ne connais
pas et je suis très agréablement
surprise à autre point positif de lille
2004 le mécénat cela la première fois
qu'une opération un événement culturel
rassembler autant de l'entreprise
et en nombre mais aussi en montants
financiers rassemblés c'était 15% du
budget plus de 12 millions d'euros et
rassemble et je pense que ça aussi ça va
continuer
budget total 65 millions d'euros tout de
même
mais lille est à présent connue du monde
entier il paraît que ça ça n'a pas de
prix